Hello, it's Crawley again. Did you miss me? Today we're going to talk about the fragility of life.
One moment a client is walking to work entirely focused on their future. The next moment, a sudden violent event changes everything.
That single second of impact is exactly why Personal Accident insurance, or PA, exists.
This concept actually started in Great Britain around 1864 during the Industrial Revolution.
To entice terrified people to ride the new steam trains, companies offered accident insurance to prove railway travel was safe.
Today, it has evolved into a major lifeline, standing at par with motor and property policies.
But in our industry, what exactly is an accident? It is an event that is undesigned, unforeseen, unexpected, and unintentional.
To trigger a claim, the injury must arise out of accidental, violent, external, and visible means.
Unlike motor or property policies, Personal Accident is not a contract of indemnity.
Why? Because a human life or a severed limb has absolutely no monetary value. You cannot put a price tag on a lost hand.
Instead, it is a valued policy, meaning it pays a specific agreed-upon face value amount for your clients.
PA is often the next best alternative to a life policy. It offers high coverage limits up to 10 times their annual income for a very low premium.
There is no medical examination required. Coverage is immediate, and the payout does not suffer from depreciation or deductibles.